AS THE SAYING GOES...LIES, DAMNED LIES AND
TWITTER...BUT SCIENTISTS ARE WORKING TO CHANGE
THAT WITH AN ONLINE LIE DETECTOR.
[MUSIC]
HEY THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
DURING MAJOR EVENTS LIKE THE CURRENT UPRISING
IN UKRAINE, THE ARAB SPRING, NATURAL DISASTERS
OR EVEN THE OLYMPICS...SOCIAL MEDIA IS INVALUABLE
IN GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
BUT JUST AS EASILY, REAL-TIME SOURCES LIKE
TWITTER CAN BE A LIE FACTORY. TAKE THE ACCOUNT
@SOCHIPROBLEMS, WHICH COLLECTED JOURNALIST
COMPLAINTS ABOUT BIZARRE BATHROOMS, HOTELS
AND GENERAL WEIRDNESS AT THE OLYMPICS...MUCH
OF IT HILARIOUS. THE PROBLEM? A LOT OF THE
PHOTOS WEREN'T REAL - OR AT LEAST, THEY WEREN'T
ACTUALLY FROM SOCHI. IN SOME CASES THE PHOTOS
PEOPLE PASSED AROUND ON SOCHI PROBLEMS WAS
TOTALLY UNRELATED STUFF FROM REDDIT.
TWITTER LIES CAN HAVE MORE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES
TOO, LIKE IN 2011 DURING THE LONDON RIOTS.
TWEETS FALSELY REPORTED THAT ANIMALS WERE
LOOSE FROM THE ZOO AND THAT LANDMARKS WERE
ON FIRE. PANIC ENSUED, POLICE WERE DIVERTED,
AND IT WAS BAD.
DURING HURRICANE SANDY, AN ACCOUNT CALLED
COMFORTABLY SMUG TWEETED OUT A SERIES OF LIES,
INCLUDING THAT THE NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE
WAS FLOODED WHICH WAS RETWEETED HUNDREDS OF
TIMES.
IN 2013, THE AP TWITTER ACCOUNT WAS HACKED
BY THE SYRIAN ELECTRONIC ARMY, WHO POSTED
THAT BARACK OBAMA WAS INJURED IN AN EXPLOSION.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS CORRECTED PRETTY QUICKLY,
THE TWEET CAUSED THE DOW JONES TO DROP 143
POINTS.
WHY ARE PEOPLE SO QUICK TO BELIEVE THESE LIES?
THAT'S A BIG QUESTION, BUT ACCORDING TO ONE
RECENT STUDY IT BOILS DOWN TO THIS - INTERPRETING
THINGS CRITICALLY IS JUST HARDER ON YOUR BRAIN
THAN BELIEVING IT AT FACE VALUE. OR IN SOME
CASES HITTING THAT RETWEET BUTTON. IT'S KINDA
HUMAN NATURE.
SO HOW DO WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF MISINFORMATION?
WELL, SOME HAVE SUGGESTED THAT IT SHOULD ACTUALLY
BE A CRIMINAL OFFENSE TO MAKE STUFF UP ON
TWITTER.
BUT EUROPEAN SCIENTISTS HAVE A DIFFERENT ANSWER
- WITH FUNDING FROM THE EU, THEY'RE BUILDING
AN ONLINE LIE DETECTOR THAT THEY SAY CAN FILTER
OUT MISINFORMATION IN REAL TIME.
CALLED FAY-MAY -AFTER THE GREEK REPRESENTATION
OF MALICIOUS GOSSIP - THE SYSTEM IS STILL
IN DEVELOPMENT, BUT THE RESEARCHERS HINTED
AT SOME WAYS TO TELL IF THAT RETWEET YOU KEEP
SEEING IS A LIE. BOTS FOR EXAMPLE ARE A FACTOR
- OR GHOST ACCOUNTS THAT DON'T HAVE MUCH ACTIVITY
ON THEM.
AND THE KEY IS ALSO IDENTIFYING THE TYPE OF
LIE - WHETHER IT'S MALICIOUS, OR BASED ON
SPECULATION OR CONTROVERSY, CONNECTING THE
TWEET BACK TO THE ORIGINAL SOURCES TO ASSESS
WHETHER IT'S ACCURATE.
SO IF WE CAN'T RELY ON HUMAN JUDGMENT TO SUSS
OUT FACT FROM FICTION ONLINE, THE EU IS BETTING
THAT COMPUTERS CAN. THE FAY-MAY SYSTEM WILL
BE TESTED BY THE Swiss Broadcasting Corporation
AND Institute of Psychiatry at King's College
London.
DO YOU THINK THIS WILL WORK? SHOULD IT BE
A CRIME TO TELL LIES ON TWITTER? LET US KNOW
YOUR REACTIONS AT DNEWS ON OUR FACEBOOK OR
TWITTER PAGE. YOU CAN REACH ME AS WELL AT
ANNIEGAUS. SEE YOU NEXT TIME.